today's one minute monday is do
something nice find something nicely you
could do for somebody in your life so
quick story a couple weeks ago I was
talk with the concierge at my building
and he was telling me about how he loved
this board game called inventors that
has been out of print since the 1970s I
decided that I would go on ebay find
somebody who had this game and I got it
for him and the cost me maybe 30 40
bucks it got delivered I had my son help
me wrap it up you put in some spider-man
wrapping paper and my son is four years
old and he gave it to the concierge and
the look on his face the concierge I
thought he was gonna cry you know it
definitely made his week it made my week
you know he started telling me about how
when he was younger he didn't have
internet he didn't have TV he grew up in
this tiny little village and all he had
was this game that he used to play with
his father called inventors and he was
going to call up his dad invite him over
and they were gonna play a game together
how great is that you can have such a
great impact on somebody's life and
again I made him feel great it made me
feel great it helped teach my son a
valuable lesson in helping others and
when you give back and you help others
it gives you more energy and makes you
feel great and you can pour that into
your business so it doesn't have to cost
you anything you don't have to spend
money on this just find a way this week
to help somebody out and has a positive
impact in their life believe you guys
like this video thumbs up below leave a
comment let me know what you think
subscribe to click on my face thank you
so much I'll see you soon
you